okay
ready to go leader thank you okay good
afternoon everybody
we will make a start with um this
evening's executive meeting
so item one is attendances i have
apologies from councillor heinz
and also from sarah todd our chief
executive
um who is at another meeting i'm not
aware of any other apologies
um no questions in terms of item two on
the agenda have been received from
members of the public
so item three is declarations of
interest
if there are any declarations of
interest from anybody now is the time to
say so
no thank you okay item four is minutes
we've actually got two sets of
um minutes this evening so we've got the
minutes of the
executive of the 22nd of june which was
suspended and resumed on the 30th
and then the executive meeting on the
26th
of october um if members of the
executive are happy to
receive those if they could indicate
please all right
thank you we'll take those um matters
from um overview and scrutiny
committees i don't know if there's
anything from counselor acting on that
yes
yeah yeah just briefly uh leader
um scrutiny committee uh did
have a close look at homelessness in
trafford and
have made a few recommendations uh which
has been
sent over to the executive and there
went
two two particular issues that um
was raised that um because of the
interest
that um was there amongst members
uh the members wanted to be kept updated
regarding homelessness in
in trafford during this pandemic but uh
and beyond
and um also i think we recommend that
uh all members should receive uh that
update
as well um so the the other issue
that we um focused in on and recommended
that the
current process for section 208
notices should be reviewed
it is a requirement that local
authorities should receive
a 2 208 notice when
a person is is to be placed within
another authority
and this really will help
to settle those people into the new
authority that they
uh are going to unfortunately this has
not been happening
in most of the authorities across gm and
i think that needs to be
reviewed um just uh very very briefly
with regard to um you know the finances
of the authority we've received several
updates on the council's budgets um
and i just like to remind members that
uh
we're holding two finance scrutiny
meetings on the first and the
third of december to consider the
executive draft
budget proposal all members are
able to tune in to the live streaming
and hopefully participate if they so
wish so that's it
thank you council acton and certainly if
we're going to be
updating scrutiny regularly on
homelessness there's no problem at all
with all members being
um kept abreast of that i think the
point about section 208 is well made
clearly over the past
nine months we've had to act at pace but
i think it's um a really important
um part of the system that adds
significant rigor so we'll take that
away
um as well and thank you for the
reminder about budget scrutiny which i'm
sure we're all
looking forward to um okay
so we will move on to the um next part
of the agenda which is
the um plane pitch strategy which is
to deal with with what has been quite a
long-running issue
around security of tenure and the
process for that so
um to introduce the council of patel
please
thank you leader this report is the
latest stage in a process to try and
bring investment and improvements to the
borough's playing pitches
it builds on the 2019 refresh of our
playing pitch strategy
a key strategic document from which
provision of long-term security of
tenure is a key recommendation
approval of this report will enable
community clubs to secure
25-year leases on plane pitches they use
for their core activity
clubs will then only be liable for a
peppercorn rent on the basis that they
take on maintenance responsibilities
many of these clubs have played on these
pitches for decades
clubs who submit an expression of
interest in securing such a lease must
demonstrate
that they are primarily or exclusive
users of the pitches
submit a business and site management
plan provide evidence of consultation
with the local community and other site
users
they must develop a robust community use
agreement with other parties
we are also also asking for evidence
that clubs proactively promote physical
activity and encourage
wider participation we currently have
very little budget to invest in
long-term facility improvement
trafford leisure with amy provide a
degree of maintenance
it isn't good enough however to meet the
needs of individual sites
only 10 of the 211 pitches in the
borough are rated as good
it is fair to say that the quality of
playing pitches and the level of
maintenance investment that can
currently be provided within our budget
is a source of concern and complaint
from community clubs
granting these leases will enable clubs
to apply for funding that the council
cannot for example
apply for support england and national
governing body
facility grants all require clubs to
have security of tenure
this new approach will also incentivize
investment from club revenue as clubs
take a long-term stake in the site
it will also encourage the pooling of
resources between clubs
critically it will develop bespoke
maintenance plans tailored to individual
sites
this is the key to ensuring long-term
improvements
in conclusion these leases will each
represent
a disposal of below best value this
report delegates future decisions to
officers
removing the need for continuous
executive approval
i recognize that seeing the term
disposal alongside open spaces may cause
alarm
i would like to reassure the meeting
that public access to these spaces will
not be hindered outside core hours
as is currently the case and as
previously mentioned clubs will be
expected to develop a robust community
use agreement
facilitating community access outside
agreed core hours
i'm currently contacting some of the
clubs who have expressed an interest
regarding the potential benefits of this
new approach
and i'll be happy to report back as it's
rolled out
thank you thank you councillor to tell
any questions or comments from
members of the executive at all
no questions or comments more wively
counselor evans
please thanks thank you uh
leader um is it just football pitches or
is it just
the general genre i i get approached
regularly and
sorry i've got no video i've turned it
on but
there we go um i get approached
regularly by ultraman district
athletics in the center of simply who've
got
i understand 300 000 pounds sat in the
bank ready to redo the
uh the running track and is it just
football pitches this or is it is it
sports grounds in general i know simply
fc will be
uh thankful for this it's welcome and is
it
sports grounds in general thank you
thank you for your question
uh no certainly not just football
pitches it applies to hockey athletics
tennis bowling
lawns um so no please um
ask your athletics club to get in touch
um
and we'll happy to to put them in get
the ball rolling
i appreciate that thank you thanks it's
probably worth noting for them nathan
that it is they are named in the report
as a beneficiary of this and i have
spoken to one of the people involved
today um on that particular site uh
council ms blackburn
thank you leader could counselor patel
just confirm
what the court hours
i are that's bespoke to each club so
it's it's when they use
um when they play their matches um
saturday mornings
sunday mornings uh it is sort of uh it
it's bespoke to each club could could
those core hours
be you know [ __ ] be changed sort of
straight away or you know do they have
to give notice
to um to the council what what their
core hours would be i think
agreeing the core hours is part of will
be part of that
um lease arrangement so it's something
that they'd have to discuss with the
council
okay okay thank you okay
i'm not seeing any other um indications
to come in on
sorry leader yeah you're right to go
back to um ultron athletics club
certainly has already
um submitted an expression of interest
just for councillor evans
thanks for that and i missed that in the
report so i do apologize no no worries
um
okay so the there are five
recommendations i
set out on page one of the report i'm
not seeing anybody else who wants to
come in on this i do think it it is
certainly a welcome step forward so
thank you councillor patel for that
and members of the executive happy to
approve the recommendations
all right thank you okay
we will move on to item seven
um highways transportation environment
and consultancy services
update and proposed next steps
councillor and said
please but before i bring councillor
outside in
um a reminder to all members that there
is a part two
for this report because of the
commercial sensitivities and should
anybody stray
over the line and into the part two
report i will have to move us there
um immediately basically or
stop anybody from talking so please do
be mindful
if you're coming in in the section of
the meeting that is open to the public
the section that we're in now
to restrict your comments and very
tightly
to the aspects covered in part one of
the report thank you counselor at please
counselor outside i think you're on mute
[Music]
so can you hear me yes come now thanks
yes it's uh
playing up again thank you leader yeah
the report
before was following on from the reports
that were approved at
executive in july and october 2019
looking at a range of potential options
for future service delivery
and updates the executive on the
progress of negotiations over the last
year or so
the report highlights the work in
relation to improving
the management and enforcement of the
contract including a refresh
of the management within amy leading to
a more responsive service and better
relationships
which has in turn led to an improvement
in service delivery as detailed
within the report the report also
proposes initiating the seven year
reboot which we are obliged to do
and provide us with an opportunity for a
full and further review of the contract
and the opportunity to look at
performance and address concerns
and propose improvement the objectives
and principles are
set out in section 30 and a full-time
table
are set out on section 32. as part of
the work although not
mentioned in the report we are proposing
the setting up of a member working group
to oversee the work around the seven
year review
and we're also looking at how community
stakeholders can also be involved in the
process
and details will be available in due
course i would
add before finishing that this
administration has not and will not shy
away from taking appropriate action
to help enforce the terms of the
contract and hold amy to account for
performance issues
when needed thank you leader
thank you chancellor any questions or
comments from members
of the executive
no okay questions or comments more
widely
yes yeah can i just uh make a point uh
just wanted to say that we our group
welcomes the
the review and look forward to the
outcome
thank you thank you councillor but
councillor coggins
please thank you later uh just to also
really welcome the review um
it's clearly been needed and i think
there has been
increased accountability and i can see
that um some some improvements have
taken place
i think it was always going to be
difficulty when we were aiming to reduce
the cost
by as much as this as this contract did
did
do and so thank you
thank you councillor coggins um okay
so don't appear to have anybody else
wanting to
um come in and just take a sec
just to double check no okay
so the recommendations are as set out in
the report are members of the executive
happy to approve those
who's that thank you
i i think probably they need to be
formally approved once the
part two report has been dealt with as
well so you can give an indication at
this stage but obviously a decision
needs to be made once you've
completed those parts well on the
institute of course thank you jane very
premature of me um but yes certainly we
will be returning to the item as i said
before in the
um in the part two of the meeting so
um thank you for that item eight is the
budget monitoring period
six report april 2 september 2020
and councillor ross please thank you
very much so the
key things to note from this report
are the slight increase to the general
budget this year
um so the budget will now be 175.52
million and that supports a little bit
more money going into the
public health line um we've had a look
at the
total covered pressures put up on the
council this year um
the bad news there is that the pressures
have gone up from 45.58 million
in september to 51.48 million
now however the net pressure when you
take into effect things like the the
grants that are coming in from the
government and other measures
has um has is now 6.59 million compared
with 8.31
million in september and in terms of our
projected
overspend that was projected to be 2.248
million
last report that's now projected to be
220
000 overspent however i'd like to draw
members attention to
paragraph eight which is in bold where
we say it is not possible
to put a definitive figure on the
projected overspend
position and that's very much where we
are it remains a moving
feast this item but um that is where we
are at period six
thank you councillor ross as you say a
very difficult year to
try and project anything for for obvious
reasons
um but regardless the paper is in front
of members of the executive you're happy
to note and prove that
thank you all right very nervous
approving that counselor ross i don't
know
quite how you worried people so much
with that but regardless
um we will move on to um item nine the
corporate plan quarter two
update councillor freeman please
thank you leader um this is the second
corporate
plan quarter report for 2021 and it
provides a summary of performance from
the 1st of july to the 30th september
although we are currently in the second
national lockdown it was
in the second quarter on the 30th of
july to be exact
traffic residents and businesses were
first put under enhanced restrictions
the quarter 2 performance has been
impacted by the coronavirus pandemic
the key performance indicators are on
page four of the report
are in red amber and green in status
for quarter two twenty twenty there are
two indicators of the red status
and exception reports have been
completed are attached to the report
the recommendation for executive is to
note the contents of the corporate plan
quarter 2 report and have to take
questions thank you later
thank you councillor freeman any
questions or comments from
members of the executive
no questions or comments more why the
counselor myers please
uh i'm sorry leed i wanted to speak on
the previous matter but you didn't call
me so i decided uh you didn't want me to
speak
thank you i've only just seen the
message patrick
do you want to if you've got any
questions on that do you want to
contact tom and nicky and i'll make sure
that they're put in the public domain
i'll do that or i'll raise
another meeting thank you sorry patrick
um
okay any questions or comments on um
on the report is just for
noting
no okay can that be noted please
i i thank you um
item 10 is urgent business there is none
so
with item 11 the exclusion resolution i
will read
the motion out for members of the
executive to consider
and that the publicly excluded from this
meeting during consideration of the
remaining items on the agenda because of
the likelihood of disclosure of exempt
information
which falls within one or more
descriptive category or categories of
the local government act 1972 schedule
12a
as amended by the local government
access to information variation order
and specified on the agenda item or
report relating to each such item
respectively um so i believe that can
that be
um agreed please second leader
thank you and that moves us into part
two of the meeting
can we ensure that the um public
recording
is stopped at this point please yes
leader if you can just give me a second
i'll cancel that and let you know when
we're we're fine to go
no problem at all